now unless there's a really big shock
tomorrow liz trust looks set to win the
conservative leadership race and become
the next prime minister one of the most
important relationships for whoever the
new prime minister will be is going to
be with the first minister of scotland
nicola sturgeon someone lives trust was
described as an attention seeker who
should be ignored well we can talk now
to nicolas sturgeon to get her take on
the leadership race but also of course
on the cost of living crisis that is
hitting people across the united kingdom
thank you so much it's great to have you
on the first show back after the summer
recess
now it's almost certain that liz trust
is going to be announced tomorrow as the
next prime minister of the uk do you
think she'll be an improvement on boris
johnson
the hard question to start with look
time will tell
it's obviously the case that liz trust
and i don't agree on very much
politically but i'm a firm believer in
giving anybody who's coming into the
office of prime minister a chance to
prove themselves and i will certainly do
my best to build a constructive working
relationship with her remember she will
be if it is indeed this trust tomorrow
she will be the the fourth prime
minister that i've had to deal with in
my time as first minister and despite my
differences with david cameron theresa
may perhaps less so with boris johnson
but it wasn't for the want of trying
i've managed to have decent working
relationships now certainly try to do
that with liz trust as well and i think
everybody will want to see what she is
going to do she faces as all of us do
right now immense challenges i hope the
very first thing she does in office is
cancel the
looming increase in energy prices the
increase in the energy price cap and
delivers some very substantial help to
individuals and businesses the one thing
i would say is that if she governs as
she has campaigned over the summer she
will be a disaster not just for scotland
but for all of the uk but let's hope
that's not the case because this is a
very serious time for the uk and it
needs very serious and very purposeful
leadership
you say if she governs as she can
campaign she'll be a disaster
why do you think that
well because she has campaigned on the
very how can i say this politely niche
priorities of a hundred thousand members
of the conservative party you know
focusing on things like
tax cuts that would benefit the very
richest when is ordinary people across
the country who desperately need help to
feed their children and heat their homes
you know there's been a focus on what
the conservatives would describe as as
walk politics you know rhetoric that
looks as if it is rowing back on the
moral obligation we all have to tackle
the climate emergency which as it
happens is also at the right thing to do
over the long term to lower energy
prices and improve energy security so
the obsessions of a tiny tiny number of
conservative party members
are not the right priorities for the
country so i think it would take very
long to see whether she is going to
govern as a prime minister with a focus
on the real priorities of the country or
not i think that will become very
obvious and evident perhaps within the
first 24 or 48 hours of her premiership
so let's hope she chooses the
responsible course and stops pandering
to
the margins and the conservative party
it does as you say feel like we're going
to find out the direction travel pretty
soon she's written in the sunday
telegraph today
saying she's going to have immediate
action on energy bills but also of
course talking an awful lot about tax
cuts
are you concerned that if she does push
ahead with tax cuts as we believe
is likely to say the least and what
impact that could have on the spending
envelope for
scotland and whatever happens do you
think you're going to have to do an
emergency budget in response to the new
prime minister
well we're undertaking an emergency
budget review right now and we are
committed to setting out the outcome of
that effectively in an emergency budget
within a couple of weeks of whatever
budget or fiscal event the new prime
minister has now we don't know for sure
when that will happen or what form that
will take but our working assumption is
there will be something of that nature
by the end of september i certainly
think that is necessary and to your
question yes i am profoundly concerned
about the potential impact of that on
the scottish government's budget and i
know my counterparts in wales and
northern ireland will have the same
concerns i mean right now we are
working within budgets that are
effectively fixed and finite they are
not rising in line with inflation but
the inflationary pressures are bearing
down on our budget as they add on the
household budgets of families across the
country any move and this is a real risk
that would cut our budgets within this
financial year would obviously be of
profound concern because it would have
big implications for the national health
service for local authority budgets for
every aspect of our spending you know
one of the things we've been trying to
do within that finite budget is help
those who most need it we have
established a scottish child payment
support that doesn't exist anywhere else
in the uk currently giving 20 pounds per
week per child to the lowest income
families we have plans to increase that
to 25 pounds a week real tangible help
at this time of crisis and we don't want
anything that reduces our ability to do
other things
to help but my other concern about tax
cuts is that they
target those who are already at the the
best off you know many people who are
really struggling right now already
don't pay income tax and wouldn't
benefit from a cut there and wouldn't
benefit in the same way that richer
people would from a cut in national
insurance for example so this is a time
to focus on what is really needed cap
freeze energy prices first and foremost
come to an arrangement then between
government and the energy companies
about how that is paid back over a
longer period of time effectively spread
and share the burden of the soaring gas
prices help businesses because
businesses don't even have the limited
protection of an energy price cap get
more cash into the the pockets of those
who need it most and free up more
spending ability for the devolved
government so we can do more to protect
public services and public sector
workers right now so there's a package
that a new prime minister could bring to
bear and it would deliver real help and
relief to millions across the uk
i guess just to put the counter argument
on tax cuts is that liz trust and those
around her would argue that cutting
taxes helps
boost growth which would then
help the economy through that sense you
mentioned as well energy bills
and action on energy bills uh liz
truster said she would take immediate
action on that there are reports that
that could include more drilling
licenses in the north sea would you be
happy to see more oil and gas taken from
the north sea to try and increase the
energy supply
but we've got to make a careful and just
transition away from oil and gas that's
an imperative for the planet right now
but actually it is the the way that we
work towards greater energy energy
security and lower
energy bills we are undertaking right
now in the scottish government our own
energy review looking at the
requirements over the longer term but
you know what is more important i think
than continuing to explore for more oil
and gas is that we fully support
the renewable energy transition so we've
just had an auction round in the north
sea which has given the initial go ahead
to up to 28 gigawatts of offshore wind
energy that's the future and that also
gives us enormous potential in green
hydrogen to help fulfill our own energy
needs but also can be a big export
potential so that's what i said earlier
on we need to support oil and gas as it
transitions and there's lots of workers
in scotland depending on that industry
right now so i'm not complacent about
that but it is the wrong priority if you
take your eye off the renewables at
revolution and the renewables transition
and that's what worries me as well as
irresponsible talk about fracking for
example let's focus on making sure that
we harness our renewables potential
which fulfills all of these important
objectives in the longer term
now i just want to talk a bit about
about independence uh you have said that
you want to hold another scottish
independence referendum in october
2023 liz trust of course during the
hosting's campaign has said if i'm
elected prime minister i will not allow
another independence referendum so she's
been talking pretty tough on it
if liz trust becomes prime minister do
you think that does impact the chances
of you holding another referendum
well look whether scotland has a
referendum whether scotland uh does or
does not uh vote to be independent it
really shouldn't be up to any uk prime
minister actually it shouldn't be up to
first minister either this is
about a fundamental principle of
democracy now there is going to be a a
supreme court hearing in october next
month that will look at whether or not
the scottish parliament has
the legal ability to legislate for a
referendum regardless of what a uk prime
minister says i hope the outcome of that
will be positive but of course that is a
a matter for the court you know what
cannot be escaped here you know whatever
list trust or any prime minister says is
the democratic aspirations of the the
people of scotland you say i want to
have a referendum next year i do but
that set the basis on which i was
elected first minister last year there
is a democratic mandate and my message
to list trust is not
to to say that i i think i can persuade
her to support independence she is
opposed to independence she's entitled
to
have that view but make the case for the
continuation of the union i will make
the case for independence and let the
scottish people decide
you know it is not a sign of strength on
the part of this trust to talk about
blocking a referendum or as some reports
today suggest gerrymandering the rules
for a referendum that is a sign of
fundamental weakness
confidence in her case for the union
let's talk about you mentioned there
about uh as you put it gerrymandering
the rules this is the reports in the
sunday times that the trust team want to
introduce
a new law that would mean a referendum
could only take place so if a referendum
takes place at least 50 percent of
scotland's entire electorate would have
to vote to leave the union for it to
happen so in other words not a simple
majority as we've seen in the eu
referendum or in the previous referendum
and for something you know as
significant as breaking away from the
union and is that something that you
would accept
no because it is a changing of the
basic rules of democracy that we have
all abided by for you know our entire
lifetime so long before that can you
imagine at the furore
the literal foaming at the mouth that we
would have had from the conservative
party if mdr suggested that for the
brexit referendum you cannot just
because you fear losing a democratic
contest
is not an excuse or doesn't make it
acceptable to try to rewrite the rules
of democracy that's my point here you
know there has never been a positive
case for the union made by those who put
forward that case in 2014 they tried and
got away with it in 2014 to scare people
in scotland i remember back then there
was all sorts of scarce stories of all
sorts of things
how a referendum could actually uh take
place because another part of the sunday
times report is saying that the uk
government wouldn't consider allowing
another referendum unless there was
evidence for more than a year that at
least 60 percent of voters wanted one if
you look at the recent polls i think we
can have a look at the yugov tracker
trackapol for
support for uh independence and you can
see that it's actually waned recently
and do you think that this perhaps
suggests that you know a time when
people in scotland are worried about
turning their heating on you know food
banks are saying that people aren't
picking up potatoes because they don't
have the money to boil them
do you think people are worrying perhaps
that independence is a distraction from
the cost of living issues
well
it's not a distraction and part of my
job is to persuade people of that
because part of the reason we're in this
mesh right now is because we're not
independent and therefore we don't have
the levers to try to navigate our way
out of that scotland was independent we
could already
have passed an emergency budget we'd
have powers to reform the energy market
to deal with some of the underlying
causes of this i wouldn't as first
minister of scotland be sitting here
right now as we were discussing earlier
on profoundly concerned in case a prime
minister in london that scotland hasn't
voted for is about to take decisions
that cut our budget even more we
wouldn't have a position where we have
to accept that people are reliant on
food banks some of the action we have
taken the scottish child payment that i
mentioned earlier on we could build on
that because we'd have access to more
levers and resources actually
independence is much uh more necessary
when we're dealing with crisis because
it gives you more levers to navigate
your way through and on to a better
future but the point i wanted to
complete it wasn't about getting to the
substance you asked me about all of
these different stories about attempts
on the part of uk governments to
gerrymander the rules
only
politicians fearing the democratic
outcome it would ever contemplate that
let's have the debate on substance where
i and my colleagues will make the case
for independence for scotland becoming
like other independent countries across
the world able to navigate our own
future and let people like liz trust
make a case for the union but then
democratically let the people of
scotland decide that's how democracy
works it's how democracy should always
work um you at the beginning of the
interview you were talking about your
relationship with other uh previous
prime ministers i just want to touch
upon your personal relationship with liz
trust because obviously personal
relationships do matter
in politics and i think i can just play
you what liz trust said
at a hustings in august about you when
she was asked let's have a listen
i feel like i'm a child of the union
that i really believe we are a family
and we're better together and i think
the best thing to do with nicola
sturgeon is ignore her she's an
attention seeker
that's what she is
she's an attention seeker that's what
she is
are you really going to be able to work
with los tras
i will do my best and it is up to his
trust to decide whether she wants to to
work with me let's put the personal
insults to one side again coming back to
the argument i made about if you're
confident in your case you don't need to
try to block democracy or gerrymandered
democracy uh similarly i'd say
just to come in and because it doesn't
make sense i do think
i do feel it is slight a two-way thing
with you guys i have to say you recently
uh said that the main thing liz trust
wanted to talk to you about uh when she
met you
uh i think um
quite recently uh was how she could get
into vogue i've just been interviewed by
vogue who said that was the main thing
she wanted to talk to me about
i remember it because we were there at
the world's biggest climate change
conference in glasgow and that was the
main topic of conversation she was
interested in pursuing just talk me
through what happened there
i was asked a question if i'd had a
conversation with liz trust it's the
only
uh
lengthy conversation or meaningful
conversation i can recall having with
list trust so i i answered the question
about what we talked about and look i'm
perfectly willing to put not to put our
political differences aside because in a
democracy you have political debates but
i will as i did with david cameron
theresa may to some extent boris johnson
i think most people would recognize that
was more difficult to build a working
relationship
i'm not perfect i'm not saying that
i'm blameless when those relationships
go through difficulties but i will try
to build that relationship but the point
i was making is that her comment about
ignoring me is in a similar vein to
trying to block democracy you don't make
a problem that you fear you can't solve
properly go away by simply ignoring it
you engage in attention then debate and
i'm a politician i mean part of your job
as a politician is to get attention for
yourself your policies your values i
mean i don't mean this pejoratively but
i've never looked at let's trust and
think thought that she was
some kind of shrinking violet and that's
not a criticism in politics that's part
of the job that you you have to do but
the ignoring point is perhaps more
fundamental because look people and some
people in scotland vote for me and my
party some people don't some people like
me some people loathe me that's
democracy but i am the democratically
elected first minister of my country and
that means quite a lot of people have
voted for me and when they hear liz
trust saying i should be ignored you
know what they hear is that scotland's
voting choices should be ignored or that
scotland should be ignored and i'll tell
you something i think people in scotland
you know are really getting increasingly
fed up with tory prime ministers that
remember we don't vote for and wouldn't
vote for if we'd had the chance with
less trust trying to ignore and talk
down scotland and that is one of the
many reasons why i think increasing
numbers of people in scotland will
support scotland being an independent
country so that that important
relationship with the rest of the uk is
on the basis of equality
okay now we are out of time but there's
just one thing i would like to ask you
it's something that i've spoken to you
about uh before i know it's something
that you feel uh strongly about um this
week my colleagues liz bakes and agnes
chamber have been looking into
allegations of sexual misconduct and the
culture
in westminster and really this crosses
across all different parties what
they've been looking into
one former snp staff member told them
the attitude in westminster is if it's
not rape it's okay
of course there have been allegations
about members of your own party the
commons watchdog found patrick grody
sexually harassed her junior member of
staff he of course has since quit the
snp
are you happy with the way that your
party has dealt with these allegations
of sexual misconduct
um no i think we can be better and i'm
not going to shy away from that i think
every party every organisation dealing
belatedly i think because too often in
the past these are things that have been
swept under the carpet i think we've all
got lessons to learn i said in the
context of the the patrick grady case
that we had lessons to learn and that is
the case so we are looking at our
procedures as a party as parliamentary
groups all of the time we've gone
through a very painful process as the
scottish government and because of
issues you and i have spoken about
previously and some of the the scrutiny
and the pressure i've had over the past
few years on these issues and in
particular the highest profile one of
these is because i've not been prepared
simply to sweep these things under the
carpet so no i don't think we are as
good as we need to do and that's
something i take seriously and i'm
intending to ensure that we do get
better so that women or men who feel
that they have been
the victim of sexual harassment or
sexual abuse feel confident in coming
forward and feel confident in the
processes that they then use
okay thank you very much nicola sturgeon
their first minister
of scotland